[Musique]
il s'agit pas au travers de cette
mission d' enquête de refaire le débat
sur le post vaccinales le sénat l'a
largement voté la question c'est de
savoir si le pass vaccinale est toujours
adaptée à la situation sanitaire si
c'est toujours un outil pertinent parce
que les connaissances sur le coronavirus
tu évolues de nouveaux variants
apparaissent est ce que il est toujours
pertinent d'avoir un pinceau vaccinale
le sénat enquêtes sur le suivi et la
tension particulière
de ceux de venir de passes vaccinale
mais aussi du devenir de ce nouveau
variant enfin qu'on appelle au micro
maintenant et qui est bien présent en
france depuis le début de l'année
la logique d'un pouvoir de créer la
norme nous parlement notre
responsabilité c'est de veiller aux
libertés publiques évidemment on est
dans une matière complexe mais il ya un
moment donné il va falloir poser les
bases de cette question de retrouver la
vie normale et que les libertés
publiques reprennent tous leurs droits
j'insiste là dessus
[Musique]